I'm obsessed with being ambitious I
think it's fantastic competitive
fantastic but if you lack patience in
that Journey you will take shortcuts and
when you take shortcuts you could
stumble or Worse throw the whole thing
off I don't see an issue with people's
ambition these days I see an issue with
their patients and that's why I talk
about micro speed macro patients on a
day-to-day basis if you're ambitious you
need to go hard 15 minute meetings lots
of them but in the macro it can take
three years and that's okay people
confuse patience with lack of ambition
when I say patient I'm not saying lazy
I'm not saying complacent I'm not saying
don't have goals I'm saying that you
have more time than you think